♪ ♪
>> Tucker: WELL, THE WORLD AS
YOU HAVE HEARD IS GOING TO END
IN 12 YEARS, IF NOT SOONER
UNLESS YOU IMMEDIATELY DITCH
YOUR CAR AND START EATING
INSECTS.
THAT'S WHAT THE PRESIDENTIAL
CANDIDATES OF THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY ARE TELLING US.
THEY ARE VERY CONCERNED, BUT NOT
SO CONCERNED THAT THEY WON'T
STOP FLYING PRIVATE.
SO WE HAVE AN IDEA FOR THEM.
WE ARE CALLING AT THE 2020 TREE
CHALLENGE.
AND IT WILL COMPENSATE FOR
GREENHOUSE GASES THEY ARE
SPEWING INTO THE ATMOSPHERE
EVERY TIME THEY GET IN THEIR
JET.
PLANT A TREE FOR EVERY MILE YOU
FLY PRIVATE.
IT IS REALLY A REQUEST/DEMAND.
PLANT A TREE FOR EVERY MILE YOU
FLY PRIVATE.
IT'S NOT HARD.
AND IF YOU CARE, YOU WILL.
THE AUTHOR OF "CHRONICLES."
AND HE JOINS US TONIGHT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR COMING ON.
SO EVEN THOSE OF US WHO ARE
SKEPTICAL OF THE DETAILS OF SOME
OF THE CLIMATE THEORY, AND A LOT
IS THEORY.
CAN GET BEHIND THE IDEA OF
PLANTING TREES.
THERE IS NO DOWNSIDE TO PLANTING
TREES, SO WHY ONE AT THESE
CANDIDATES TAKE US UP ON OUR
TREE CHALLENGE?
>> WELL, NOT ONLY THAT, BUT
NUCLEAR POWER, THE NUCLEAR POWER
AND PLANTING ENOUGH TREES, LET'S
SAY ACROSS THE ENTIRE WORLD THE
SIZE OF CANADA WOULD OFFSET THE
CARBON DIOXIDE PRODUCTION BY
MANKIND.
AND THE QUESTION IS, WHY WOULD
YOU NOT TRY THAT?
IT IS MUCH LESS EXPENSIVE BOTH
WAYS, FOR ONE.
THERE MUST BE SOME OTHER REASON
THOUGH.
AND YOU KNOW, THERE ARE TIMES --
>> Tucker: WHAT DO YOU THINK
THAT IS, JOE?
>> WELL, WE BOTH KNOW WHAT WE
BELIEVE IT IS.
BUT I DON'T THINK THAT THEY WANT
THIS TO GO AWAY, I THINK THERE
IS ONLY ONE ANSWER THAT THEY
WANT, AND THIS IS A NEW GREEN
DEAL, WE CAN ALL GET BEHIND.
LET'S PLANT MORE TREES.
AND BY THE WAY, IT IS
FASCINATING WATCHING THIS,
BECAUSE YOU KNOW, PLANTS GROW
BEST AT ABOUT 1500 PARTS PER
MILLION OF CARBON DIOXIDE.
AND WE ARE CURRENTLY AT 410
PARTS BY CARBON DIOXIDE.
THERE IS A NATURAL SYNERGY
BETWEEN ANIMAL LIFE AND PLANT
LIFE, PROBABLY SOMEWHERE IN
BETWEEN.
BECAUSE ANIMALS INHALE MORE
CARBON DIOXIDE THEN THEY INHALE,
YOU ARE A CARBON POLLUTANT
ORGANISM, YOU ARE.
THEY LOVE THAT.
THEY GET THAT AND THEY GROW.
IN FACT, TUCKER, IT IS GETTING
DANGEROUS OUT THERE.
I HAVE TREES TRYING TO HUG ME.
BECAUSE THEY KNOW HUMAN BEINGS,
WELL, THEY DON'T KNOW THAT, BUT
THE FACT IS THAT THE PLANET IS
NOW GREENER THAN IT HAS EVER
BEEN IN THE SATELLITE ERA.
A CIRCLING BACK TO WILL HELP
HER, THIS IS EXACTLY THE POINT
THAT HE WAS MAKING.
WE ARE PULLING OUT OF A CO2
DROUGHT, THE CLIMATE OPTIMUM IS
THE BEST TIME FOR LIFE ON THE
PLANET IS A LITTLE BIT WARMER
AND MORE CO2 IN THE AIR, AND
THAT HAS BEEN ESTABLISHED FROM
THE KEY ILLOGICAL HISTORY.
SO WHY DO WE GO AND SPEND
$10 TRILLION TO SAVE .01 CELSIUS
OVER 30 YEARS WHEN WE CAN TRY
THIS?
>> Tucker: THERE IS NO
DOWNSIDE TO PLANTING REDWOODS
AND EASTERN WHITE PINES.
IT IS ALL GOOD.
OF COURSE IT DOES NOT INCREASE
THEIR POWER.
SO I DOUBT THEY ARE FOR IT.
BUT WE WILL KEEP PRESSING ON OUR
TREE CHALLENGE.